winter is coming and I'm liking where
it's going Mockingbird this season
continues to just blow me away it's all
steadily moving forward there's a great
building climax of the season as a whole
but each individual episode still
manages to be really entertaining unto
itself now this episode doesn't have the
big set piece that the last episode but
it doesn't matter because even though
it's largely building towards what's
going to be coming next episode and the
setup that they're giving us is
fantastic even though it's all building
towards something else it's still really
great to see everything get going there
and seeing where everything's evolving
to some of it is very clear you see
where it's going some of it is a bit
more oh okay that's new it's a nice mix
of the two it doesn't feel overtly like
twist but it doesn't feel completely
predictable either it's a good balance
at King's Landing Tyrion has to deal
with the aftermath of what happened at
the end of the last episode and it
leaves him in a bit of a vulnerable
place and an interesting place just to
see where this is all playing out for
him he has a really good scene with
Bronn where they just do what they're
always great at Brian giving the guy a
dose of reality in terms of what the
nature of their relationship with it and
what the nature of the world they live
in is bran was always really good at
that harsh truth told in an amusing way
and he does that again Oberyn Martell
I'm just every time we see him he's just
more and more intriguing maybe it's the
accent I don't know there's just
something intriguing and exotic about
this guy it's like a very clearly where
he's going in at least in the immediate
future and I can't wait the mountain
comes back after being shown
sporadically across the number of
seasons and talked about incessantly
he's finally back disembowelling people
for the heck of it so pretty much what
you'd expect but this guy oh he's
intimidating I mentioned before this is
the third actor that I've gotten to play
this part but oh my god I don't know if
he's as big as they make him look but
he's like the Hulk at Dragonstone I
continue surprisingly to me to find lady
Melisandre evolving in an interesting
character I really didn't care for her
when she first got introduced I liked
her even less last season but you know
what she's really got some depth to her
and as much as she is
a true believer in this in this Lord of
the light and all of that she has a
pragmatic side she has a practical side
so she's not just this one-dimensional
fanatic that said the fanatic girl seems
to now being taken on by Stannis's wife
who I'm not gonna say she's bugging me
but I'm like you're gonna be a problem
and I know you're gonna be a problem cuz
nobody is as devout as you as blindly as
you and doesn't end up being a problem
I'll put the wall I am having a little
bit of issue I am again starting to
actually enjoy watching Jon Snow which
again surprises me because like most
Sansa I didn't really care for him
before but I'm liking where he's going I
like how he's evolved over time
unfortunately the obstacle they've now
got in his way is just it's so blatant
and so obvious and it's so generic
he just keeps butting heads with the
hood the new head of the Nights Watch
and I look at this guy and you know I
just think to myself God say well you
just either wise up or die he's like the
mayor in Jaws you're just there to keep
the people who know what they're doing
from doing a good job of it you're just
you need to go away and I understand
from a storytelling perspective either
necessary obstacle but it's such an
obvious way to stall things and make
things more difficult for Jon and the
shows better than that Brienne and
Podrick still loving that pairing and
Patrick is able to show that you know
what he does have some value maybe he's
not a seasoned fighter maybe he's not
even really cut out to be that much of a
squire but he starts to show that no
he's got some value and he's got some
things that he brings to the table Arya
and the Hound more fantastic stuff just
to see Arya continue down the path she's
on I'm she's just so good to see where
she's going and to get a sense of what
she's gonna end up as and there's just
some great callbacks as well to stuff
that happened I did two seasons ago and
we get a little more depth into the
Hound now I was a little cautious about
this when the scenes started and he
started talking about his past I'm like
I'm not sure I want to know that much
about you because he's one of those
characters it's kind of cool because you
don't know much about him and I thought
getting that backstory might take some
of the edge off well it doesn't he
maintains his edge maintains his cool
still working fantastically across the
Narrow Sea
Daenerys yeah well there's stuff going
on with her and Daario that I'm
I could go either way I'm but she still
like to talk to go for having to find
that balance between a conqueror and a
ruler and it's nice to see her develop
this other side to her in addition to
the kick-ass leader she already was
guess who's still stealing the show
though Baelish again just this guy and
what's really amazing about this episode
though is you get the side of he
actually at one point was capable of
love you again you get some history and
some backstory you get this real sense
of him that for all the stuff he's doing
now there was something redeemable in
him once I'm pretty sure it's gone now
though so just where everything ends at
the end of this episode where
everything's pointed to where it's going
I could not be more excited for the next
episode and like I said just the season
overall is just really got me back into
the show the last season yeah I got a
little iffy towards the end of it there
but I'm really loving this oh you know
what I want to give a shout out to some
of the kills in this one because you
know what last season we got brutalized
a lot of really hard difficult to watch
kills I got a I got a number of more
just really satisfying kills in this
episode and you know what I'm gonna give
a shout-out to that cuz I appreciate
them so that about wraps it up on this
one let me ask you this though if you
found yourself in the land of Westeros
and you had to have a companion at your
side in a battle who out of this cast of
characters would you want at your side
when the chips can get thrown down and
you need somebody to help you fight your
way out of situation who would you take
into battle leave something down in the
comments and let's talk about it until
next time this council is adjourned